[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman who
got covered and now she feels like she
is a germaphobe she wants to know what
to do we talked to a woman whose
brother's an alcoholic and she doesn't
know how to talk to him we talk to a
husband who just wants to fight better
with his wife and we answer the question
am i on cocaine stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john delony's show man
what a wild week we are having glad
you're with us
hope you're having a great day
thanks for joining us to talk about
mental health relationships education
family
how to reconnect how to be humans again
so glad that you're here it's awesome if
you want to be on the shows triple h oh
no it's not triple eight two eight two
five damn it's the wrong show it's one
eight four four
six nine three
three two nine one
that's like it's like i feel like i'm
calling my new girlfriend an old
girlfriend's name when i do that it's
not great
and i for sure have done that before
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask
and her name is susie not sharon
what i never dated a sushi or sharon
oh well all right two
cool things one is hilarious james
one is just really kind so hey everybody
keep mailing me letters
this is like i feel like i'm just got
home from summer camp and
every day i come in and there's letters
that you all write with your hands and
paper
and number one the paper y'all find is
incredible because i can tell most of
y'all haven't written a letter in
ever
and it's so fun but these letters are
great
but i've got to tell you something about
the internets james let me find it here
i'm looking on my cellular device
and i'm speaking as though i'm 117 years
old so the other night um on the
internets
my my wife she published a like a small
book and it was it's incredible so good
we did an instagram live
and we had a friend of ours who lives
over in east nashville he's an artist
he's just remarkable his name is eric
peterson um
he was on there too so we were just
taking questions and everyone always
wants to know like i never met my wife
and so this is like the big reveal like
she exists
and anyway
so somebody that night after the
internets after this ig live we just
took questions about anything everything
was fun
and is a little bit like ghostbusters
cause me and my wife don't cross the
streams like
she doesn't listen to the show that
sounded like a peeing reference it is
not um
but she doesn't watch the show she just
does her own thing and i do my own thing
and i'm in the cold toe in the morning
and she's under the covers writing and
so we're just very different people
but since somebody writes in from the
internets and this is phenomenal here's
what they write
they she this woman is really kind and
says a lot of great things about this
show um
says some rude things about y'all too
but it's cool actually she didn't then
she says this
i'm never
ever anyone that would hurl something an
accusation i'm not sure why it's on my
heart to even say this now
but um
your live video was a little strange
and you owe me no explanation obviously
but you seemed
under the influence of cocaine
all the typical physical mannerisms of
your face and mouth movements and your
speech patterns
i'm not saying this to shame you or even
say it's true i'm simply saying that if
you're using a substance for whatever
reason whether coping or
enjoyment that for the first time i
noticed it tonight on your ig live
maybe i have an astute i for a variety
of reasons dot dot dot
ps you're worth being well ps
so a couple of things
i've been around the cocaine a lot in my
life i've never done it i i wasn't doing
cocaine with my wife on an ig live
who does cocaine at nine at night anyway
you gotta go to bed
but that's beside the point and actually
people who do cocaine are like kind of
anytime's a good time to do cocaine so i
don't know when we started watching
clocks weirdo but so that's an aside so
for this sweet person who
saw it and thought oh no
i wasn't doing cocaine but
i showed my wife this to show her
that people on the internets just have
their thoughts and feelings about you
and she read this and goes
finally somebody understands what i have
to live with every day
and that made me sad and then she's like
i'm gonna show all my friends this and
then she has and they're all like yeah
we can see that that your life is pretty
awful
so
two things one i kind of want to do
cocaine now just to see what would
actually happen if this is my life
and two james you've spent a lot of time
with me
do i do i have speech patterns and
behavior mannerisms i've never seen a
lot of people that are high on cocaine
but you definitely have what i feel like
is cocaine energy a lot of times so
don't do it because it would just double
back on itself and yeah i know i think
it'd create a wormhole in the universe
my wife tells me i'm a lot and i think
she's probably correct
i think uh you should be thankful a lot
of people would kill for the energy that
you have a lot of people do illegal
drugs to to get like this
to get this body so haha like that
america this comes naturally
if you think i'm i'm on cocaine i'm not
i'm kind of a downer i think anyway
hey
in other news i got a letter and we'll
read it
dear dr john
hello
after listening to the podcast that came
out on my 35th birthday of all days
where the caller asked how do i know if
i'm an alcoholic you said a few things
that hit me in ways i didn't expect
as a casual drinker who could stop when
i wanted to that's what they all say and
didn't experience problems per se i
noticed that i was struggling with
exactly what you said scratching and
clogging my way through the morning
after a few drinks and not giving myself
a chance to feel my absolute best
since that day i quit drinking alcohol
and i feel like i've regained control of
my life in a way that i didn't know i
needed for the first time in years i
wake up before my alarm i'm in the gym
at 5 a.m several days a week i'm more
present and clear minded at working with
my two young daughters and my sleep has
been the best of my adult life yeah
that's awesome and i just said yeah like
we were in a gym or something like an
idiot i didn't mean to say it like that
but
um my husband has joined me in this
venture and our relationship has never
been better
i've learned so much from listening to
your podcast and from the books you've
suggested currently reading chatter by
ethan cross excellent book i agree
thank you for what you do
and then some other nice stuff dude yes
and hey that's what this show is about
taking one degree
shift what if i decided to instead of
yelling i got quiet for a minute what if
i when i felt angry i actually asked
myself what am i angry about instead of
just
going after my child or what if i just
tried a few weeks without drinking what
happens or what if i actually start
having a glass of wine at night because
i never drink ever ever ever and would
that help me fill and play
yes yes yes so good for you i'm not
gonna say your name cause you didn't
tell me i could but
ar thank you so much
for your letter all right let's get to
the calls let's go to caitlin in
west palm beach florida what's up
caitlin
hi dr d how are you i just want to say
i'm
really excited i'm excited i'm talking
to you a little nervous um i followed
you from the very beginning
super honored that you would even take
my call
well i'm grateful for you that's uh it's
really kind that you even reached out
and
lucky for you you may get some cocaine
energy even though i'm not doing drugs
listen like james said i'm super jealous
because
you have to buy your drugs
yeah i mean coffee starbucks is like the
equivalent of street prices anyway
[Laughter]
exactly and the lines are longer hey so
what's up caitlin
okay so
i had covet about a month ago
how are you
how are you
i'm much better now good was it pretty
rough i'm
it was very rough mentally more so than
physically i
assumed because i had the vaccine it was
like a breakthrough um
but mentally i already struggled with
anxiety i already struggled with ptsd
um and this whole experience was just
you know when people ask me about it i
just say it was really traumatic yeah it
was traumatic for me
um
since then
i have developed
ocd is what i've been told um
specifically contamination ocd
oh man are you germaphobian out like
crazy i am
yeah full on
um like doorknobs
freak me out and
buttons and
you know just
yeah it's all about either germs
or
getting sick again or getting someone i
love sick or other people sick
yes um i've never dealt with this
problem before i've never had these
feelings or thoughts or worries in this
way before
i do have to say that it has
eased up a little bit
since like the initial you know coming
out of kovid
but
i just can't shake the like
you know in the back of my mind i'm
always thinking i'm always thinking
about the buttons always thinking about
the doorknobs i'm always thinking you
know absolutely
you know
of course the doctor is one to throw
medicine at me but i just kind of feel
like
i would rather
i feel like i have the mindset and the
willpower to work through this
you know
i've sought therapy i've been told to
try
exposure therapy with no
you know real explanation of how to do
that and
so yeah i'm just hoping i gotcha where
there's a will there's a way right i got
you uh sort of sort of okay um i
but it's gonna work exactly opposite of
how you think it is so let me ask you
two questions real quick to help me
frame this um
anxiety what's what's what is that
trying to tell you
do you have childhood trauma what's the
psd ptsd from
i have childhood trauma and then i have
a significant other we're not married
but you know we have a kid and all that
who has a substance abuse problem and a
lot of stuff with him okay all right so
you've got
so the way i frame anxiety and i'm gonna
walk you i'm gonna reverse engineer
where we are okay the way um
the best i can tell biochemically and um
both biochemically and relationally
anxiety is just an alarm you may have
heard me say this a thousand times
that tells your body you're either
out of connection with the relationships
so it's an ancient it's an ancient alarm
system letting you know you just woke up
on the planes and you were all by
yourself and you were probably gonna die
so it wants you to reconnect the second
one is the alarm that is letting you
know you are not in control of your
situation
you are out of control somebody else has
autonomy over you
and then the third one is just a
generalized alarm that says you're not
safe right now
and
i just want to tell you really quickly
is that
the anxiety
that i feel now it's almost as if you
know when i had the covid i was so hyper
sensitive of what am i feeling what are
my symptoms what's gonna happen what's
not happening you know to
i was on this like high alert
and it's almost like i can't turn it off
now yes okay so here's the beautiful
thing about the system and it's
devastating at the same time it's like
watching an explosion it's so beautiful
and it just is so destructive
um
when you an and it could be a hundred
things from your childhood i'm gonna
pick one randomly and just go from there
okay
uh but you know this runs deeper than
what i'm about to say
so you're
in relationship with an addict and
you're trying to make it work and
sometimes you participate and sometimes
you don't so you get shame and guilt too
and then you have a kid and then you
have this picture of what my life was
going to look like with a kid
and
it is anchored to an addict
and so the boat you are on is rocking
always it's never stable and underneath
all of that you have lost
control
and your brain begins to tell you every
day we got to get control back we got to
get control back we got to get control
back and then you've got some patterns
that you learned as a child which is
either hide or to over correct
and i when i just said overcorrect think
of a steering wheel your hands just some
people when the when they hit
hit um they're about to have a wreck
they literally let go of the wheel the
car is in control and others clamp down
on it my guess is you're a clamper am i
on to it yes okay yes
so yeah
here's the beautiful thing
our bodies get addicted to that clamp
it surges
with all sorts of stress hormones and it
gets addicted to it and the sucky thing
about anxiety is when those alarms start
they start looking for everywhere we
don't have control we're not safe
yeah and then it i called it the great
transference my when i had it super bad
it would just move from thing to thing
to thing and i would eventually solve
for that thing and then it would just
move to something else it would go from
the stock market's collapse and we're
gonna have to eat our pets too then it
would move over to
climate stuff and then it would move
over to this and it kept moving on me it
would never stop
and then a real thing would happen
and then finally my body would go oh we
know this script
so am i am i reading it am i walking
down the line so it goes from
trauma real trauma relational trauma and
you're out of control then your body
sounds the anxiety alarms and then it
picks up in all kinds of ptsd it just
experiences your past trauma in the
present all day every day you're having
all these thoughts over and over you're
replaying everything and trying to gain
control over something that happened a
long time ago
and then you get covered
and you did everything right you tried
to control it you got the vaccine you've
been taking care of everything you're
being safe and you got it anyway
and now what happened is your body
realizes one damning thing
you're in control of basically nothing
nothing yeah
and it either you either let go of that
steering wheel or you uber clamped on it
and now you don't want to touch a
doorknob a button and there's a lot of
semantics in the ocd world
um about is it an anxiety disorder
different part of your brain i don't
care about any of that crap
it's it's a as far until somebody proves
me otherwise it's a continuity it is
when your body says oh you're not
getting our message we'll take over for
you right
and we will make sure you can't get out
of this build we want you to be so safe
that we're just going to walk you in a
circle for the rest of your life right
yeah that's what it feels like yeah yeah
yeah and so here's all for exposure
therapy here's all exposure therapy is
let's say you have a phobia of snakes
and if you get around snakes your body
re like you'll vomit it will lock down
not like i hate snakes but it shuts down
your body
exposure therapies when you go to
counseling and somebody will sit with
you and they will on the other side of
the room show you a picture of a snake
that's it
and they will let you'll feel your body
did you go through all this
i haven't done it yet okay so in that
you start with a picture and then you go
progressively until you've got a snake
around your neck and you're just holding
it and your body quits reacting for you
and we think it's about thinking it's
not it's about our body taking over and
all exposure therapy does is it it it
lets our body reconnect and go okay
we're safe
and by the way when you're doing this
you're working with a counselor and
you're establishing a relationship your
body is reconnecting with the human and
so you begin to over time your body goes
okay we're safe they're safe they're
safe they're safe just establishes trust
and then your body quits overreacting
and so technically that's exposure
therapy a lot of people try to go home
and would use your words which are
um
willpower
i'm just gonna keep grabbing this
doorknob over and over and then i'm just
gonna lick my hand after i'm gonna lick
the doorknob
and i'm gonna go stick my hand in the
bathroom in a gas station and then i'm
just gonna eat right i mean like
what i'll tell you if you do that your
brain will revolt
yeah that's not willpower is the worst
so when i somebody tells me they try to
just grit their way through ocd grit
their way through anxiety
that is
that is
bringing a a malt like a what do they
call them a molotov cocktails i say it
too to try to put a fire out it's nuts
it's the exact wrong thing
here's where willpower works
if you will commit to submitting to this
thing
okay so it's reverse you don't want to
overdo it you almost want to under do it
you want to just complete submission to
it
so i've had every and the reason i'm all
man i feel like i'm talking too much i
i'm all passionate about this because
i've been down this road i was
vaccinated and i got it too i had a
breakthrough case too it was a mild case
and it was it was hard it was hard yeah
it it made me bonkers right
yes especially you know i'm really
extroverted
and
to be stuck inside for 14 days yeah
i mean i just
mentally it was
the hardest thing i ever did yeah but
it's hard because
you're
you're a clincher
yeah right you're a grasper you want to
control it through force
and anxiety loves that it just but it
makes the anxiety loop spin faster and
faster and faster
and so
this is an oh i mean it's an old
meditation practice
the practice you have ahead of you is
letting go
not okay not pushing through
i guess my question is
if i don't force myself to
touch doorknobs and do things that make
me
extremely uncomfortable
how do i oh i want you to you're gonna
you're gonna do that you will okay but i
want you to do it a different way
okay so
here's a couple of things you've already
you noted it a little bit your body will
relax
when it realizes it is not in danger of
germs it will over time it will
um your body's
so i want you to make peace with your
body and don't go to war with it
all your body's trying to do is keep you
safe
and it doesn't think it lived through a
pretty traumatic situation as a child
it lived through a really traumatic
situation with your
uh partner like an abusive addictive
relationship
and so your body thinks that you don't
know what you're doing that you're not a
good driver and it's going to drive for
you
okay
so i want you to make peace with your
body that's trying to help you out and
stop fighting it
ptsd is about trying to continue a war
that's already over
so yeah because i'm just always reliving
it yes
so
as soon as you can make peace with the
fact that the war is over your body will
go back to it it doesn't want to fight
it just feels like it has to
and you caitlyn are not um taking care
of us and so we're just gonna fight for
you and so
make peace with your body all it's
trying to do is keep you safe
and that safety
uh it's like smoking right it feels good
at 10 15 in the morning and
you got friends
and you got
you know um
it helps you feel a little better and it
kills you next year but right now it
helps that's what this is doing okay so
two things number one when you come to
the door i want you to
come to the door
and say i'm gonna practice that's the
magic word practice not fight practice
okay all right
and your body will gear up and i want
you to go oh man thank you for taking
care of me this whole thing is about
posture the behavior is going to be very
similar but it's all about posture
you're trying to take care of me i
appreciate that
i'm going to touch this doorknob now
and
we're not going to die
and the whole time i want you breathing
this thing okay
and then i want you to touch that door
knob
or i want you to push the button
let me ask you real quick though okay
after i touch the doorknob
do i immediately sanitize my hands which
is my current instinct or do i also
let that go and just be like
well we're okay you're going to you're
going to practice
and so let's say you cut in this i mean
it could be about 50 different things it
could be about the doorknob so you touch
that doorknob
and then you hold it and then i want you
to let go of that doorknob and i want
you to feel your hand
for the first time again and you've
heard me say jocko calls it detachment
if you're a navy seal and michael singer
who's like a
a great guru says it you know it's
mindfulness i want you to feel your hand
and i want you to ask your body what are
you doing right now
because you're not helping body like
what are what are we doing and i want
what you're doing is you're separating
yourself from your feelings and we're so
overdriven with our feelings we feel
like we have to respond to them
our feelings often don't tell us the
truth so we got to acknowledge them and
then we got to decide so you're going to
touch that thing and then literally look
at your hand and go okay body what are
we doing
and when you do that your body goes oh
she's driving now we're good
and it may you may
say all right we're going to do this for
30 seconds i'm going to sit here for 30
seconds and i'm going to feel like an
idiot but i'm going to sit here for 30
seconds and then i'm going gonna go
sanitize my hands
and the practice part is there's not a
failure here
the practice is i'm gonna go for 30
seconds that's it
and i'm gonna you hear my voice like i'm
just gonna be curious about my body i'm
not gonna go to war with myself because
it's trying to help and then tomorrow
i'm going to try a minute or tomorrow
i'm going to go 15 seconds and then in a
week you're going to be exhausted
and probably had too much to drink the
night before and you're going to try it
and it's going to be awful and you're
just going to push the button and go
through you didn't fail anything you're
just practicing i missed the shot that's
all right i'll take another shot
tomorrow
and you're gonna lean into the practice
here
what you have to teach your body is no
we are not in control and that's okay
it's okay
we're doing the best we can with the
information we got i got vaccinated i
thought that was the right thing to do i
did it and i still got sick i got less
sick maybe but i got sick and i'm gonna
go on to the next thing and your body
will learn with you
so this is gonna sound bonkers you're
going to take control by letting control
go
okay okay
you are going to teach your body yes we
are not in control and yes that's okay
there is five or six things that we can
control and i'm gonna triple down on
those
i will not hang out with addicts i will
make sure i'm eating right and taking
care of my body and exercising and those
things that help with anxiety way
upstream i am gonna be disciplined i am
going to read
and when crap happens i'm going to smile
about it and then get on to the next
thing
that's what we're that's what we're
working towards
okay okay yeah cause those are all the
things that i i know i know i know i'm
not done
so
we're gonna go all the way upstream
create a world where anxiety can't exist
because your body will know oh no she's
driving and she's a good driver she's a
great driver
and we're going to create a world that
when it hits
and i hope you never get rid of anxiety
it's good for you it lets you know
you're not okay or it signals to you you
need to take a break or you got to be
around people or you got to get back in
the gym or don't eat a box of twinkies
anymore it doesn't feel good it will
it's a good signal for you
but it will begin to ring when it's
appropriate not just all of the freaking
time
you are right in the right path so
practice be curious
and the goal here is
really begin to refine what you can
control and what you can't
and i'm telling you i've lived it
anxiety will
it will dissipate it'll show back up
when it needs to but it will dissipate
i think you can get here without
medicine i really do
i really really do
if you can go see your doctor it's all
right again we're practicing we're
leading into it and it's going to be all
good dude you're a rock star katelyn i'm
glad you're feeling better lean into it
man and
your willingness to ask
to be to be brave here is going to help
a bunch of people i'm grateful for you
we'll be right back on the dr john
delonay show
show that a lot of us dread going to
sleep at night maybe it's because we're
stressed because we didn't finish
everything during the day or because our
thoughts just won't stop spinning or
maybe our spouse snores so loud or maybe
our bed's 100 years old and it's just
not comfortable whatever it is
anticipating a bad night of sleep sets
us up to be miserable we get better
deeper rest when we look forward to
sleep and that's why it's so important
to create a sleep environment you love
jumping into for me the mattress is
critical but also pillows are key i hate
bad pillows but i got my dream cloud
mattress and they sent me these dream
cloud pillows and dude
they are incredible i can't wait to go
to sleep and you know what that helps me
sleep better now pillows aren't the only
accessory dream cloud makes to optimize
sleep they have luxury sheets they got
mattress protectors you name it and
today when you order a dream cloud
mattress you get
399 bucks of these incredible sleep
accessories and on top of that dr john
doloni's show listeners get an
additional 250 bucks off that's 649 in
savings not to mention some really good
sleep if you need better sleep check it
out at dreamcloudsleep.com
promo code deloney
all right we are back let's go out to
philadelphia i was born and raised on
the playgrounds where i spent most of my
days and talked to lynn what's up lin
hello dr john how are you thank you for
taking my call i'm hanging in there
hanging in there awesome hey you haven't
let go let go yet so that's fantastic
what's
so um
my brother hey hold on hold on yeah
i'm trying to get better on this show
about um what's coming
and your side tells me i'm just guessing
i'm stone guessing here
that you know what i'm gonna answer
whenever you ask whatever it is you're
gonna ask
um no
no i don't all right i'm not there yet
okay i thought i was getting better at
this job i'm clearly not it's awesome
okay so good i wouldn't work through
that and then not call because i would
have figured oh that's what he's going
to say so i don't need to call okay
awesome okay let's do this all right so
your brother
my brother he is a long-term alcoholic
with anger issues and he's been that way
for
30 years at least
um
so my my family myself and my daughters
we're not close to him for obvious
reasons but
were
close or social with his wife and their
kids
but we never discussed my brother
um
there's
there was a recent event with him that
kind of has blown up
into the family
with with the kids who are in their
twenties okay uh the hell is this guy
uh 61. okay all right but my
sister-in-law doesn't want anyone to
know what's going on inside their house
what happened
well just i mean
again years of just emotional abuse he
well something happened you know did
something happen so what happened he was
drunk he
fell injured himself was hospitalized
my niece was trying they were trying to
use this as an opportunity to
not have him come home but go into rehab
or go to the va
my one of my other sisters
he was reaching out to her not giving
her the full story
and dragged her into it and she ended up
somehow
enabling him to go back into the home
so
now my
nieces and nephews are furious at my
sister
because it kind of screwed up their
plans
you know so everyone's like
it's all awkward and but again with my
sister-in-law not wanting anyone to know
pretending nothing's going on
with the holidays coming up when i'm not
sure
you know do we just all go back to
pretending
everything's fine
um meanwhile you know i heard you
describe it in a protocol how the kids
are living in this hurricane or tornado
and that's what i feel like for their
for those kids yeah um they still live
at home
yeah they're all in their young 20s just
in college or finishing up college
so they've they've
they've lived this forever
yes exactly and nobody
man
nobody's helping them nobody came to
their to their rescue
nobody rescued these kids
and i'm heartbroken for him
i am too um and i mean i always knew it
he was not pleasant but i figured it
wasn't
i didn't know until now that it was as
bad
as but you knew in the uh so
you knew i mean you knew
right
and there's there's some guilt over
should i have stepped in should i have
said something and all that i think it's
important to own that guilt okay
okay and here's what this your family
system needs
in a desperate way
is for somebody to start telling the
truth
because your brother became a secret
he became
a shameful shadow in your family system
and
but how can we do that when his wife
doesn't it's your
brother i mean frankly i feel like
writing him up i mean i'm on her
i'm more worried about her and and the
kids
and that's how we all kind of feel
because as i'm hearing as i'm learning
more information from my niece and my
kids talking
the things i experienced with him
growing up
is
being repeated you know
i know
okay here's what's happening
you sh
i don't say you should the time for
intervention was when these kids were
six
they're they're adults now they're
grown-ups
and they have to live in a world where i
had a
raging alcoholic as a dad a mom who
didn't protect us family system that
didn't protect us and now we're
grown-ups and now we're gonna have to
make grown-up choices
you've heard me talk about the bricks
and the backpack thing i was at an event
um a few weeks ago in florida and i've
never been asked this question
a parent got up and said
you know your presentation's you know i
love it i i'm thinking about all the
bricks i got to deal with
but more importantly i realized that
i've put bricks in my kids backpack how
do i help them get theirs out i've never
been asked that question and here's the
the hard answer
you can't
that's their journey now
and
our parents goal is to put as few bricks
in their kids backpack as humanly
possible because the world will put
plenty in them they're kids and they'll
make dumb decisions and they'll have
their own to deal with they'll be adults
and they'll have moments where they
don't make great choices or seasons
where they make great choices they have
to deal with their own
but once they're in there that is their
adventure to to to heal and get that out
a parent can't reach back in their
parent can make it easier they can say
i'm sorry they can say i screwed this up
they can help financially
but that's the kid's job
and these kids got it left
and so you as how old are you
55 yeah i mean
you can't get in the middle of somebody
else's family system it's over the
ship's sailed
yeah what you can do and i think you
feel real guilty and you see it and
you're trying to re-correct it
and
there's a
not with you i'm not going to point this
at you i'm saying your family system has
significant immaturity running through
it it's y'all acting like kids
hey we can trick him into or we can okay
now we got an opportunity to
it's like y'all are building a fort out
in the woods and yeah we got this stick
and we found this board and we
this is somebody's life you can't trick
somebody into rehab
you've heard me say this you got to go
in there and flip all the lights on turn
the music on and say this dance is over
and
looking at sweet sister-in-law i don't
care that's my brother and i love him
and i'm gonna look him in the eye and
say i love you enough to say i'm scared
i don't want you to die
and
if you want help i'll walk with you
that's it
and i know y'all don't want to blow up
the holidays the holidays are blown up
well yeah yeah and we've made our piece
with them
no it's not it's not it it
there oh here's here's
you can only work forward
what's happened has happened
i think
it would be helpful for you to write
yourself a letter
and say the things to yourself here's
what i should have done and i didn't
here's what i wish i had done and i
didn't
here's how i experienced that guy when i
was a kid and i was scared of him
still i'm scared of
him and trying to help him peripherally
but he's just a nuclear reactor and i'm
scared of him
and here's what mom and dad contributed
to that
and
here's where we are now
because everybody's trying to do
everything at once and it's just all
weird and
childish and what about that i mean
somebody's got to be an adult
and you can't go fix his a 20 year old
kids
you can tell them you could take them
out for lunch and say i should have
stepped in as aunt lynn and i didn't and
i'm sorry
i know what y'all went through
and if you need anything from this point
forward i'm here for
you okay
i can do that
with with my sister-in-law
i mean
i guess i'm worried then if
bringing it out into the open then she
cuts off contact with me she's a
grown-up well right
here's a question you gotta ask yourself
um
do
am i gonna be okay at his funeral in 18
months
because he's doing he's he's on what i
call a long tail suicide
yeah he's checked out
he's not he's not pulling a trigger
today but he is doing the best he can to
drown himself slowly
and it will escalate he's 61 so that
ball will get is going to start rolling
downhill real fast
and he'll end up with some sort of heart
disease or cancer or some sort of thing
that pops up or he'll slip and fall and
break a hit whatever's happening it's
going to start happening with with
increasing speed
yeah and so i want you to imagine
yourself at your funeral at his funeral
standing next to your sister-in-law and
going good thing we didn't say anything
i feel good about that good call
if that's the right choice for you rock
on to the break of dawn
i have i have made it my
life's mission to have no unspoken
conversations
and there are four or five throughout my
life that i can't do over again and it
kills me
but my family will know
if i think they're gonna kill themselves
they're gonna know they're gonna have to
go through me first
they're gonna at least have heard what i
have to say about it
and they're gonna know that i love them
and they're gonna know that if they need
something i'll do the best i can to help
and then if he wants to keep on drinking
and being angry and being full of rage
and whatever he can do that he's a 61
year old man and if this 20 year old
kids want to keep living in that toxic
sewage
they're 20 year old kids that i mean
they're in their young 20s they can do
what they want if they're going to take
his money for tuition and deal with the
abuse and the beatings and watch their
mother just get stepped on
that's their choice they're adults i
think it's a terrible choice
i tell them to keep shoves money i'm
going to be on my own i'm going to go
get help i'm going to be live healthy
i'm going to stop this
nonsense
but that's their choice
and i can't say that when i was in my
20s i would have made a different choice
i'm just old man now
but all you can't you can't trip
somebody and kind of nudge them into
rehab and you can't use this as an
excuse to do a thing so you can do
somebody's gotta quit being immature say
this is what this is gonna be
and everybody lynn you included have to
start living for today and tomorrow and
not trying to i don't know this is the
past in it i'm gonna what are we gonna
do today i'm gonna solve this today it's
my brother
i'll tell my sister-in-law i love you
i'm not gonna i'm not content to sit on
the sidelines when my brother dies and
he drags his entire family down with him
i'm not so i'm gonna say what i'm gonna
say i'm his sister and i get to do that
and then after that then she gets to
make her grown-up decision if she wants
to take her ball and go home
well god bless her hope she doesn't hope
she says finally somebody reached out
[Music]
it probably won't happen
just picture yourself at his funeral
what are you going to say to the wife
then
how hard will that conversation be be
right back on the dr john alonso
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why because
they're committed to doing what's right
for you and that means walking you
through paperwork that's way over your
head that means making sure you get the
right mortgage that you can pay off as
soon as possible and they'll try to
upsell you a bunch of nonsense that's
going to hurt you down the road and most
importantly when you're making this big
life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
hola we got umass let's go to will in
casey what's up will how we doing man
i'm good how are you doing awesome
awesome awesome
it's gonna say awesome awesome but that
just feels weird i don't want to ride
where i'm from
you got possums everywhere
uh yeah we got a lot of possums they are
not awesome
no they're not they're pretty gross
they're disgusting yeah they're like
gigantic rats that their faces are they
just look angry all the time anyway
yeah i want to get a mean letter from
the the possum lobby so let's go we can
move on what's up dude
i think possums are beautiful
i've known a few people like that and i
don't understand they're everywhere well
they're possible people are everywhere
they interrupt you while you're deer
hunting you know that's always i know
and then you have that weird choice
you're like do i i don't i don't blow
the whole thing anyway yes gotcha
all right so what's up oh hey armadillos
an abomination they're evil they're the
worst
yes they're like the evil child
offspring of a pig they're the worst
i agree it's like if a pig
and a rhinoceros had a child
and then it just
honey i shrunk the kids four and it just
got small and then it just destroys her
oh they're the worst okay what's up
sorry um oh it's all good i agree
uh so my question is is um
how do i fight better with my wife you
know i'm looking for all of the uh you
know punches and pulls on how to win no
i'm just kidding but
uh really my wife and i went to a
marriage conference um with dr les and
leslie parrott
and
you know the thing that i took away from
that was that my wife and i are
different fighting styles so
if that makes sense fighting types so i
or my wife is high expressive
and low flexible
and i'm the opposite i am high flexible
and i am low expressive oh sweet so when
you get in a fight and she
she flips the lights on and is hollering
and screaming and you shut down
she views your shutdown as
you don't love me you don't love what
we're talking about
and when she sets off
you feel like
whoa
yeah yeah pretty pretty close to that
sounds great awesome so yeah why do
y'all
les is a good friend of mine i love les
lesley they're awesome
why do you fight
um
you want like like examples of fights or
yeah like what's your last fight what
was it about
um
last fight was on uh
communication um
that seems like a great thing to fight
over
yeah yeah yeah exactly um
that and then yeah my family was another
fight we had um so what's a fight look
like
so
typically it's um
i mean i
i'll throw her under the bus she usually
is the one that starts them because yeah
i mean she's a you know flip on the
lights or she's offended by something
and you know she's ready to go she's
ready to brawl and uh
so
i mean when you say when she says she's
ready to brawl does she hit you did she
no no
yeah i should have made that more clear
uh no she doesn't hit me does she get
loud what is that what do you mean like
what is a fight
so
yeah when we get into a fight um
she gets you know she's high expressive
so she gets very emotional she
she does yell sometimes she's gotten
better
um some you know if she go it comes it
kind of comes and goes in waves uh you
know you sometimes she does pretty good
sometimes uh i mean she just she gets
mad and
upset and so she'll yell
um i want to back out real quick when
you get in a fight you get emotional too
yeah and we often blame women for being
over emotional because they get loud
yeah they may wave their arms or
whatever
the men i know get hyper-emotional too
they just turn it into a nuclear reactor
yeah they internalize it and then they
weaponize silence and they weaponize or
they get rage that trapped anger right
and so i think everybody in a fight gets
emotional one just may look different
and then i know other idiotic men who
get over emotional and they're screaming
and yelling and acting like they're
four-year-old morons so yeah like just
to kind of get to right to the heart of
it yes um
fighting's about ego
and most marriage fights are not about
the thing we're fighting about they're
proxy wars
and
my experience with people who are
what did you call them high expressive
yeah
is they are trying to drag feelings out
of their partner
okay please just show me you care
please
please tell me that you hear me
on 20 different things we just happen to
land on this one
and other folks who are more
um
your emotion goes inner it it's the duck
under the wall like the feet are kicking
under the water but i'm holding it down
and i kind of laser everything down like
that intensity like the like the death
star array
it really could get all these lasers
come together and i'm gonna shoot one
laser and it's gonna nuke everything but
i'm only gonna shoot one and then i'm
gonna look like i'm the one in control
that person just wants can we just
level out here
and so
when anybody's gonna fight
i know the cool thing is like we fight
well and fight good
i'm gonna tell you man i think by and
large fighting is stupid
yeah
and where i landed on that was i
if you and your wife fight
and she wins you both lose
yeah you both lose if you win a fight
and halfway through she realizes she's
being like histrionic and she's all over
the place and
then she feels ashamed and then she gets
mad that you made her feel ashamed and i
wish she could just respond like you do
and how do you stick
everybody loses
and so when somebody asks me how do i
fight well
my first answer is don't fight
don't fight
the second thing is and i know you're
like all right dude you don't know my
wife
you don't know what i'm dealing with
real cool man
no
here's the here's the big takeaway
okay
fight the problem not each other
yeah
and so if you can
so here's here's a fun way to do it
so one of the things like i'm a huge
huge huge huge obsessive fight fan
like that's my that's my soap opera
drama who's fighting who who's the
rumors about fights who's their new
coaches their workout programs it's
embarrassing okay yeah i'm like a child
in baseball cards when it comes to
fighting um i don't ever ever watch the
news i go through my mma websites every
day
who's fighting who and who said what
about who's
like that's just my little drama for the
day
and one of the things i love about
fighting is
in a bar somebody bumps you you get mad
at them and you all just like a fight
happens right there it's never about
that bump it's about somebody's
exhausted they've had too much to drink
they're just trying to let off some
steam this guy's mom is not doing well
and then it all erupts here what i love
about professional fighting is two
grown-ups say i'll fight you for the
right dollar amount and then we're gonna
plan on it six months from now
and every day i'm gonna go to the gym
and i'm gonna do what i can to fight you
the whole thing is preposterous and i
love it
and then we work really hard and we
train and we watch film and we we plan
but if you notice in a bar fight one guy
goes to jail
one guy's like oh yeah and then they
look each other up on social media and
they continue to talk crap and then
their girlfriends get in a fight
whatever
at the end of a ufc fight they hug
yeah because it was never about that guy
it was always about the fight was the
issue yeah okay
and so
what i would love to see in your home
when your family's coming over and
you're you forgot to tell your wife
they're gonna come at two instead of
five
yeah and she's like you always and it
just sets off
yep i would love it to go okay
let's let the issue be the war here not
me
can
we prepare for the next thing can we
prepare for this fight you can't do it
in a fight and that's where most people
fail it's where less is awesome most
people wait till the fight to try to set
up the rules for the fight
once a fight set off in a bar dude there
is no rules i'm throwing chairs we're
hitting each other with bottles like the
fight is set off yeah the ufc is cool
because everybody knows the rules
gotcha right you can't kick somebody in
the face when they're laying on the
ground like there's all the rules so
yeah you set those up way ahead of time
because you put two trained fighters in
a ring and they're gonna they're gonna
go for it so they have to practice
upstream okay okay so i want you and
your wife to set our new family ground
rules for fighting
okay anybody can tap out and say we're
going to do this later
anybody and i'm kind of making this fly
here it's kind of fun for me anybody can
tap out here's the rules for the fight
if somebody um groin shot
then i get five minutes of a break
because that's a real thing in ufc if
you kick somebody in the in the in the
wedding tackle they get five minutes
take a break right so if somebody
screams too loud
or somebody said you say
you're getting emotional it dude that
just sets it off
yeah everybody gets five minutes okay
um but it's
getting out and setting up the rules for
the fight before you get in there
and then really dude i know all of the
i'm this kind of fighter i'm that kind
of fighter
i get that as a context
yeah i don't buy that as a way of life
yeah i get that as recognizing my
default setting this is where i need to
start from
is not an excuse to
have silent rage it is not an excuse to
throw bottles and vases in my house
so as somebody who's married to somebody
who's an expressive fighter
who is passionate about your
relationship
what
what i'm saying does it sound bonkers or
is your eyes just rolling in the back of
your head like oh this dude doesn't know
what an idiot
no no no it all sounds really good i'm
yeah i'm just trying to yeah just know
what i can do better for sure and i i
agree i mean setting up
a plan that way we know how it goes
would really help
i do think there's moments for intense
passion i love it
but i always want it to be about the
thing we're trying to solve not about
winning each other
winning over each other
yeah everybody listening to this
a one
or a loss in a marriage relationship
everybody loses
and it's whether like i'm i'm going to
we always eat at your restaurant i'm
going to my restaurant and i'm getting
my burger and fry
everybody loses
everybody loses
why over a burger seriously half
enchiladas do chill out just stay at
home and have what a protein shake i
don't care everybody loses or something
big like i want that house well i want
that house and then we're going to go to
war
and then somebody gets their house
everybody loses
and so i want the ground rules set up
and then i want to be like why why why
am i so passionate about this why am i
so passionate about that can we find a
place where we come together in the
middle here
and
can we find the that you and i will not
fight with each other we will get really
hyper and passionate about the issue and
we're going to sit on the same side of
the table when we fight
and we're going to put the issue on a
note card in the middle of the table and
we've already talked about the rules so
this is the fight and i'm going to tell
you you do this much prep fighting goes
away
it's just trivial it's dumb
it's just dumb and in my house now when
i start getting my pouty
my wife will say i'm not fighting you
or i'm not doing this
it's like
oh well that's kind of dumb then i guess
i'll just start talking
it's just it's it's nonsensical so it's
just like
it's it's like you get home and your
kids are all hiding so they're playing
hide and seek and you just turn all the
lights on you're like i'm not playing
hide and seek i'm just going to the
kitchen and all the kids are like oh
it's lame it's like that
i just don't think everybody's got a
fight
i think fighting should be reserved for
really important quiet moments she comes
home and she says i've cheated on you
you sit down and say hey i've got eighty
thousand dollars in credit card debt
that i didn't tell you about
um she says hey i
just quit my job i mean there are
moments for fights they're important
that's why the ground rules set up way
in advance are so important that's why a
commitment to let's make the issue the
issue not me defeating you
great call will grateful for you brother
all right as wrap up today's show during
the break james brought in
the song of the day so i'm flipping it
over here
it over here
good james
i see this one
oh even better here we go
a little bit on the nose
no pun intended
song is by eric clapton and it's called
cocaine
there were a wealth of songs about
cocaine by the way i just there are that
one gold dust woman by fleetwood mac
life in the fast lane by the eagles
good job i'm gonna go with eric
clapton's cocaine
and it goes like this
if you wanna
hang out you've gotta take her out
cocaine
you wanna get down down on the ground
cocaine she don't lie she don't lie she
don't lie
cocaine if you got bad news you want to
kick the blues cocaine when your day is
done and you want to ride on
cocaine
if you want to do an ig live with your
wife to celebrate her book on prayers
[Music]
not cocaine
not co not cocaine
see you soon on the dr john de luna show